that's how it all works i mean the
democratic party at this point is the
party of hating trump they don't have
anything else they don't have any
policies that are effective that anybody
likes look at this whole fake inflation
reduction act it was full of
things that aren't going to help anybody
all all they do is they boost chinese
industry in you know solar somebody's
got to do that well someone's got it it
may as well be us it may as well be our
tax dollars the big way that they're
going to pay for this bill and reduce
the deficit their whole plan is to
collect taxes from us
audit us right not not not audits
they talked about audits they're talking
about audits
no no no hold on
audits will happen middle and lower
income people will be audited but it's
not the main issue they're also raising
our taxes they're they're probably not
doing that and this is the game they're
playing biden comes out and he says we
are not raising taxes on anybody who
makes less than 400 000 and we're not
going to be increasing audits on these
people that's the trick what's really
going to happen anybody who runs a
business knows this june you get a
letter in the mail from the irs and it
says you owe us an additional 1 593
send your check here there's no audit
there's no dispute an audit implies they
want to be fair with you and make sure
they're getting the numbers right they
don't speak the thing oh i see they just
send you the bill
and this is this is why because that's
what they do to me every year i get the
my account does the thing he says you're
gonna get this much money back and then
when i get the money back i get way less
and the government says we actually took
a whole bunch more yep
and
i'm i'm i i know so many of you
listening this has happened to you that
they're they're me every year the
federal government and new york state
and the city and this is where i see all
the conservatives making a big mistake
when they're saying things like
oh they're gonna they're they're lying
they're gonna audit you it's like well
you know look maybe there probably will
be more audits washington post even said
it's gonna be middle-income people
there's more money to be gained out of
going after lower income people than
going after rich people yeah because
lower income people aren't going to do
anything they're just going to be like
oh they took a bunch of my money i still
have to get little johnny but the audits
implies the irs is being fair with you
interesting to to assume that you're
going to get audited is to assume the
iris is like we'd like more money from
you but we're going to give you a chance
to prove you don't owe it no you're
saying it's just another like everything
additionally is another rhetorical trick
of course
like the climate like the climate thing
the climate thing in the bill is uh if
you can afford to redo your house you
can get some credits by putting solar on
it that's if you have a house and can
afford to redo it
well the last few months of this
congress has taught me a valuable lesson
about the power you have when you have a
majority is you can essentially just
troll the ever living crap out of the
opposition into voting against something
that should be considered highly popular
but you you may you give it a popular
title but do things in the bill that
don't actually do what that title
implies and there have been so many they
do that all the time yeah but there have
been so many instances like it's just in
the last like couple months we had the
inflation reduction act which is not
going to reduce inflation anyway they
had the pudding baby formula on the
shelves act or something some crap like
that which i think the only thing that
bill did was give the fda more salaries
and expenditures the fda which caused
the baby formula shortage in the first
place but they were able to claim that
republicans voted against baby formula
they've done like so many things like
this the american uh rescue plan or
whatever yeah are you feeling are you
feeling rescued right now i'm not you
know it's getting worse you know i just
read i read that um farmers are having
to like
like destroy fields because the droughts
are so bad the plants aren't growing
anymore and they they can't they can't
make it work meanwhile the department of
agriculture decided to give out grants
and loans based on uh the race of
farmers yeah and this nobody talked
about this this was like over a year ago
and then courts struck it down finally
and was like oh actually you know what
that's discriminatory we have this crazy
thing called the civil rights act
you can't really do what's the situation
they were doing with farmers uh so the
department of agriculture during covid
decided to give out a bunch of grants
and loans to farmers right to help
farmers out but the way that they
decided to do it was to prioritize
non-white farmers
and their reasoning was that this would
be a correction for past discrimination
done by the department of agriculture
and eventually you know a bunch of
farmers brought suit and said that's
discrimination and a court finally said
you know what you can't discriminate in
the present to try and correct
discrimination in the past but they're
doing this all over the country too not
just with farmers like there was just a
story that i saw the other day out of
minneapolis
which you know minneapolis has just
become a ridiculous place but the
minneapolis school board
just just the school district or the
school district they just they got a new
contract with their union that said in
the event that the school needs to be
downsized white teachers get fired
before minorities regardless is
regardless of seniority that's illegal
that is literally illegal
and you know what like there was a lot
of backlash because of course that's
remarkably discriminatory and racist
and the school district was like we're
going to do it anyway we think it's
correct and they have the same argument
which is that it corrects for past
discrimination
but we already have this precedent you
can't discriminate in the present to
correct discrimination in the past well
they're doing it they're doing it anyway
so this is the issue cultural
enforcement is always way more
way more powerful there are some
instances where you could discriminate
in the present like say there were two
warring parties and one warring party
killed all the fathers and then took the
children as slaves and now they own all
the land and you're like well we the
children now of the dead fathers are
like we want our land back they're like
sorry you can't discriminate against the
conquerors in the present because of
what you're like yo actually we can you
just killed my dad like i can definitely
discriminate against the guy that
murdered my father you're talking about
the individual
there are situations where you can
discriminate in the presence to to make
equal like equality of opportunity but i
don't think this is one of them right
right so discrimination in the most
literal sense is not what we're actually
talking about discriminate means like
when you choose to go down a road that
looks better
we're not talking about that if you're
talking about
a group of people that committed an act
of crime in real time and then we were
like hey we're going to stop that and
bring about justice yeah we have a civil
court for that yeah but it's like
criminal and civilization what happened
like 60 years ago and now they're all
kind of established all the conquerors
now own the land you're talking about
reparations talking about colonialism
and reparations yeah that's sort of a
different situation i don't think that's
what the department of agriculture was
trying to do because they weren't
talking about colonialism they were
talking about the department of
agriculture having previously perhaps
discriminated against or in favor of
white farmers there's also going to the
supreme court it's a little different
going to the supreme court in the next
term is going to be a case
involving harvard discriminating against
white and asian students there's a
lawsuit over that that's going to be and
harvard keeps oh i'm sorry guys and then
it's gonna and and they're gonna and and
you know what's hilarious about that is
the biden justice department the biden
administration who makes a whole they
brought bts to the white house to talk
about how we have to stop asian hate
they are literally defending harvard in
this case the doj filed an amicus brief
defending harvard's discriminatory
admissions practices against asians
harvard actually keeps saying that they
should discriminate against asian
students and they've also said
in talking about why it's important for
them to discriminate they said if we're
not allowed to discriminate then how
will we be able to judge entrance essays
that talk about people's you know
difficulties being racially whatever
that's their argument that's not an
argument it's not a good argument no
it's total total trash that's the
they're just racists well that's the
thing about like this well harvard was
racist like they owned slaves yeah yeah
that was the thing though about like
when stop asian hate became like a huge
hashtag like as if out of nowhere racism
was happening against asians and it's
like the biggest source of racism
happening against asian americans is
happening on the admissions boards of
ivy league colleges well and high
schools
high school literally literally in all
across the country but like the focus
was as if there's like white
supremacists out there who are all of a
sudden well discrimination there is a
disproportionately large amount of
asians at these schools and they can't
have that they don't they don't like the
fact that
there's a community that for some reason
other uh uh prides themselves on
academia or something like that well you
know and so what i the way to try just
the way i describe it to people is if
you're in favor of this then here's what
i want you to do
i want you to go to
uh some inner city kid who's asian and i
want you to be the one to explain to him
why he's not allowed to go to an ivy
league school because he looks too much
like those other people
well exactly the thing that it shows too
is that democrats don't think that
minorities are americans
they think that they are separate right
and need to be treated some separate and
different way
so they're the ones they're like
actually racist they're bigotry
it's the whole thing yeah
so they don't think asian kids should
get the same opportunity as americans
they don't think that black kids should
be held to the same standards as
americans and they're the ones who are
differentiating and deciding that the
people who are getting everything are
the white people and that everybody else
needs to be treated some different and
special way and it's like meanwhile like
anyone who thinks reasonably realizes
that all these kids are obviously
americans and deserving of the same
opportunity to excel on their own
marriage i think some of them aren't
america isn't it the thing is that some
are for kids that are foreign coming to
heart but once you're
i don't think that's it i think it's
mostly american asian-american kids
this also like hurts like this this type
of mindset also hurts them like i
remember
there were these huge stories that have
gone around in the last year about how
like inner city schools in baltimore and
san francisco and in all these other
places
a lot of the kids like couldn't read
past like a fourth or fifth grade level
yet they were passing all of their
classes like they're they're
deliberately inflating their gpas you
know and that's like hurting them like
how does that help somebody when you
give when you when you deliberately
inflate their gpa because they're a
certain race even though they can't read
past like a level that they should be
able to well now that they have at
lowell high school in san francisco now
that they have
made it more of a lottery system so that
you can get in regardless of what your
grades are
the grades across the board have gone
down like the school is not serving
students as well academically as it had
been they're also now rolling out a lot
of schools this equity
you know equity diversity grading system
which takes race into account in how
grades are calculated
which is ridiculous yeah it's crazy and
that's and that's why speed this is
actually another positional enforcement
i work i work with a pack
part of my my i didn't really introduce
what i do at the beginning of the at the
top of the show i did my toast till his
chaney being defeated
but what i might i work for a company
called x strategies and we work with a
lot of conservative organizations doing
consulting and digital work and one of
the people we work with is a school
board pack who are they're called the
1776 project pack shout out to my friend
ryan gordusky and they are a pack that
is seeking to replace school board
members with people who won't do any of
this crap they've done a very good job
of it and it this it's important that if
you want to get this out of your schools
to vote in school board elections
because a lot of the ways that these
woke school board members get in that
leads to all of these policies is the
fact that very very few people know when
school board elections are happening
at all and so next week in florida
there's a lot there's a primary election
next tuesday and
the the governor and the senators races
obviously desantis and marco rubio are
going to win their primaries by a mile
but
your school every county in florida has
a school board election on the ballot
and so
the fact that these big races that get
all the nash get all the national
attention may lead to some republicans
staying home you can't stay home because
your school board is on the ballot and
if a candidate gets over 50 in these
elections they automatically win wow and
so republicans if you if if you're
watching and you are a parent in florida
you need to vote in your school board
election next tuesday because that is
how because like a lot a lot of these
stories you're seeing about woke school
boards are happening in
insanely red areas and it's literally
and the reason they get in is because
only the teacher the people only the
teachers unions know that the school
board elections are happening and they
get their people to vote and all of the
everyone there stays home well it's been
so interesting too to see desantis going
out and endorsing candidates for the
school board i've never seen anyone
endorse candidates for school board
before and now i get like press releases
about like who desantis is endorsing
first time to start paying attention
yeah these are important elections
these local elections impact your life a
lot more than national than these like
national elections do a school board
election has a direct impact on you in a
way that a congressional election does
not now it's important to vote in both
obviously but there is a distinction to
be made
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there